after World War two with most of Europe
and ruins tension grew between the
Soviet Union and the United States it
was clear that the next global
superpower required the ability to both
launch and successively defend nuclear
attacks from intercontinental ballistic
missiles in North America the most
vulnerable point of attack was over the
North Pole
so in 1958 a joint effort between United
States and Canada was established known
as NORAD or North American Aerospace
Defense Command an important line of
defense was the semi-automatic ground
environment it was an automated system
of over 100 long-distance radars
scattered across North America they were
connected to computerized radar stations
that transmitted tracking data using
telephone lines or radio waves all of
this radar information was sped into a
primary warning center buried a mile
deep inside Cheyenne Mountain in
Colorado this application of machine to
machine communication allowed operators
to make split-second decisions using
information transmitted and processed
automatically by computers this idea of
being online was quickly adapted and
advanced by universities in the
following years as they understood the
potential of computer networking the
thing that makes the computer
communication network special is that it
puts the workers that be the team
members who are geographically
distributed in touch not only with one
another but with the information base
with which they work all the time and
this is obviously going to make a
tremendous difference in how we plan
organize and execute almost everything
of any intellectual consequence if we
get into mode in which everything is
handled electronically and your only
identification is among the plastic
thing you stick into the machinery then
I can imagine that they want to get that
settled up with your bank account just
right now and
through all the checks and that would
require Network money transfers were
just one of a growing number of
applications which required encryption
to remain secure and as the internet
grew to encompass millions around the
world a new problem emerged at the time
encryption required two parties to first
share a secret random number known as a
key so how could two people who have
never met agree on a secret shared key
without letting Eve who is always
listening also obtained a copy in 1976
Whitfield Diffie and Martin Hellman
devised an amazing trick to do this
first let's explore how this trick is
done using colors
how could Alice and Bob agree on a
secret color without a finding it out
the trick is based on two facts one it's
easy to mix two colors together to make
a third color and two given a mixed
color it's hard to reverse it in order
to find the exact original colors this
is the basis for a lock easy in one
direction hard in the reverse direction
this is known as a one-way function now
the solution works as follows first they
agree publicly on a starting color say
yellow next Alice and Bob both randomly
select private colors and mix them into
the public yellow in order to disguise
their private colors now Alice keeps her
private color and sends her mixture to
Bob and Bob keeps his private color and
sends his mixture to Alice
now the heart of the trick Alice and Bob
add their private colors to the other
person's mixture and arrived at a shared
secret color
notice how Eve is unable to determine
this exact color since she needs one of
their private colors to do so
[Music]
and that is the trick now to do this
with numbers we need a numerical
procedure which is easy in one direction
and hard in the other